أنت تفكر حقًا في الطبخ بالغاز،
خاصة أن الغاز الاحترافي هو الأكثر
قوة وتحكمًا، وهو في الواقع ليس هو
الحال على الإطلاق،
ما هو الطبخ التعريفي،
فهو يعمل من خلال وجود ملف مغناطيسي
يعيش تحت سطحك، حيث
تقوم بتشغيله ويخلق مستوى منخفضًا آمنًا
موجة مغناطيسية تحول المقلاة إلى
وعاء تسخين،
أنا الشيف روشيل باوتشر وباعتباري
طاهيًا خاصًا سابقًا وطاهيًا لشركة
في عالم الأجهزة، فقد كنت
محظوظًا جدًا لأنني عملت في مجال الحث
لسنوات عديدة
مع كب كيك الحث هناك
دقة شديدة  توجد الآن أيضًا أدوات
تحكم حيث يمكنك الحصول على
درجة حرارة محددة، لذا إذا كنت أقلي الدجاج،
فيمكنني تحويل هذا الزيت إلى درجة مثالية تبلغ 350 درجة
ويبقيه هناك بغض النظر عن كمية
الطعام التي أقوم بإضافتها
ولكنك أيضًا تحصل على حرارة فورية عندما
تكون كذلك  الماء المغلي على سبيل المثال،
سوف يغلي الماء الخاص بك في نصف الوقت الذي
يُعتقد أن التسخين بالحث أو الطبخ فيه
أكثر كفاءة من الغاز لأنك
لا تحتاج إلى
لهب بدرجة حرارة عالية لتسخين الجزء السفلي من
المقلاة، حيث تصبح المقلاة نفسها ساخنة
يجب أن تكون أواني الطهي مغناطيسية، هذا
هو القفل القديم الكبير من الحي الصيني
طالما أن المغناطيس يلتصق
بالأسفل، فهو يعمل. جميع متاجر أدوات الطهي لديها
على مدار السنوات العشر الماضية مغناطيس
خلف أسطح العمل الخاصة بها حتى تتمكن من اختباره
بالحث، فهو آمن للغاية ولا يوجد  لهب إذا
كنت أقوم بقلي شيء ما، يمكنني وضع
المناشف الورقية في كل مكان حولها، فلن
تشتعل فيها النيران أبدًا، ولكن هناك
حرارة تنعكس
من المقلاة، لذا ضع في اعتبارك أنها قد
تحرقك ولكنها ليست بنفس
خطورة اللهب  أو الطراز القديم
المسطح الكهربائي
عندما يكون لديك موقد غاز، فإنك
تحرق الغاز ويولد ثاني أكسيد الكربون، وإذا كان
الموقد الخاص بك لا يعمل
بشكل صحيح، فمن الممكن أن يكون لديك تسرب للغاز،
وهذا الغاز لديه قدرة أعلى على الاحتباس الحراري
من مجرد غاز  ثاني أكسيد الكربون
بحد ذاته
من عيوب الطبخ بالحث هو أن
الحث أصبح أكثر تكلفة الآن إذا كنت تقوم
ببناء منزل جديد، فمن
التوفير الكبير استخدام الكهرباء بالكامل باستخدام
الحث لأنك لا تقوم بتشغيل
خط غاز ويمكنك توفير الكثير من المال
على الحجم  من غطاء محرك السيارة الخاص بك، ومع ذلك، إذا
انكسر شيء ما، فقد يكون من الصعب
العثور على شخص يعرف كيفية إصلاحه،
بالنسبة للمستأجرين للأشخاص الذين يرغبون في
تجربته، يمكنك الحصول على وحدة توصيل
تسمى "الموقد" ليست بنفس القوة ولكنها يمكن أن
تعطيك حقًا  لديك فكرة عن مدى روعة
تعلم هذه الأشياء، فهي تستغرق يومًا أو يومين تقريبًا،
ولكن بمجرد أن تعتاد على
فوائد الحث، ستغير قواعد اللعبة